puis vous fait fantasmer ludivine qui
vont observer au hasard de fantasmes à
la télévision ajourné à il il est tout
ce que j'aime ah bon pot charismatique
posé intelligent vous allez mettre le
feu alors désolé j'ai une ans harry
roselmack jaoui finalement c'est vrai je
comprends ce valide sais pas s'il est
notée spectateurs valide aussi mais
c'est vrai qu'il est beau intelligent
posez vous avez raison pas mal celui-ci
on est d'accord on est d'accord au
couple ou caroline alors moi c'est nikos
ah bah oui ça vient ça oui c'est bien
une thèse qui vont jamais cru compris
place avaient tort ou que sais-je
rentrer avec lui j il peut prendre et
sur unis la série x avec sa femme et
leur bébé bien sûr sortir chez lui parce
que et ça va vous faire paraître très
bizarre même et il ressemble un peu à
mon père ne le contredit l'affection
pour lui immédiate
oui d'accord
helou penser à sa dette grecque tout de
suite à la feta tout ça maintenant ok
très bien
aline je le note il faut qu'on prenne
part des couches et l'obstination
d'amiens alors moi c'est une femme que
j'ai rencontrée à l'occasion mon premier
stage seront repeints lorsque je devais
accueillir les invités du grand direct
des médias
mais quel âge j'avais très exactement 19
ans d'accord non attendez je vous dis
des bêtises 21 enfin bref il s'agit de
daniel gilbert l'animatrice des années
70 à will do et cave et une silhouette
très appétissante et c'est la première
femme qui a vraiment généré des pertes
de transpiration dans mon dos pour la
première fois on promet elle est
vraiment très très joli et franchement
un chapeau elle bon d'accord ok je
m'attendais pas je m'attendais pas à ça
très bien mais on va très bien écouter
et aider alors oui bien sûr vous savez
que j'adore connaître un petit peu de
vous et de votre jardin secret
exactement
et donc comme cyril personne et mon
délire alors dire ça voilà par lé parce
que madame regarde par émission avec
elle
et du coup j'ai donné une personne pour
qui j'ai beaucoup d'admiration alors
peut-être pas un fantasme c'est clément
victorovitch
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les maris corovic ferait que ça regarde
le brio et brillant mais fantasque
c'est vrai quand on est on était plus
sur un registre fantasmes bon vous me
connaissez le trouver beaucoup trop mais
que c'est un garçon qui est très bon
c'est un orateur ex on perd un peu comme
moi et peut-être un territoire tout
genre connaît les têtes tuent parfois un
peu jaloux il a une qualité je trouve
extraordinaire dans le débat dans
l'argumentation donc je suis vraiment
fan de lui je l'apprécié énormément
d'accord ça se limite à dire une
relation amicale d'aviation mais je suis
honoré et donc vous vous êtes défilé sur
le choix d'une jeune femme il y en avait
pas personne et mon de dire à part votre
épouse qui ne travaillent pas la
télévision et ville à mal maintenant
voilà un problème bien sûr ça va sinon
au niveau du canard vous faites bien le
canal
[Applaudissements]